we're on the overtime okay 50 years
after the Voting Rights Act are
minorities still being disenfranchised
yes next question yeah yeah I mean one
yeah please yes I'm sure you can the one
time black people voted in an election
equal to whites was when Obama got
elected he's a senator yeah well yeah
for same class but and and guess what's
been happening cutting it back ever
since against black oh yes I mean big
time oh yes I D laws voter ID laws no
like you Luisi
you got a hip ID got it oh yeah sure you
got it no I mean the demographics as you
well know are against the Republican
Party so answer cheat okay um he's so
gullible oh yeah yeah
learned that in catechism he understood
answer yes a you know I still have my
bag yeah yeah I see your scars I don't
know I was gonna even know I'm gonna say
and you're against me I was gonna say I
still have the way I could smell the
weed from
Hey
but I said I still have the mimeograph
sheet that they gave out with all the
questions that we had to memorize 100 of
them like where is God God is everywhere
then why do I have to come here all
right
will Hilary's plan to make college more
affordable win over a key demographic
Wow who's writing these questions like
[ __ ] though today wait wait wait today
though I mean if anybody who watched
this this week she's talking about
massive investment in college
affordability allowing students to be
able to refinance their loans at regular
rates rather than these ridiculous rates
but today today she did something really
interesting which was that she she
unveiled a portion of the plan that
allowed for parents working parents to
be given grants and services so that
they can go to college as well as make
sure that their kids are taken care of
really important for some others to live
why did you decide to release your album
for free well maybe because no one buys
it any now all feeling yeah I feel it
anyway yeah people don't don't buy music
they'd rather stream and pay money to
streaming companies horrible um you know
and it's convenient you know as as
horrible as it is it's my responsibility
to do something about it is not on the
consumer to do something about the new
business model and so the way I disagree
with that well it I mean I don't think
it's fair but that's how it is
it's my responsible I don't think it's
fair I wouldn't say that about it you
wouldn't say that about civil rights
it's just how it is it's not fair it's
not what is it's not quite as tactics
and strategies so I have a website now
quale club.com you come to my website
Ryan Leslie or RB artist great guy he
built it for me you come to my website
you log and I get your email I help
people with their homework I listen to
demo tapes all that people come by
directly for me we sell but we saw your
book there we sell books wait you help
people with their home oh yeah people
have sent me their homework and I've
helped them with their homework Wow we
sell we sell books we sell art I sell my
music and in order to get people there I
have an album called [ __ ] the money part
of me
and so sorry
oh boy that offends me terribly sister I
good I have fans who have come there
support me all year quality club calm so
I'll give him a free album you know to
keep them coming in you know I don't
want to mass market and try to canvas
the whole market I want to market to the
niche of people who really support me
and you didn't Jam it in everybody's
iPod like you do you should be right
definitely
that's a venal sin right when you say a
bad word that's not what you deliver and
all that was pre Vatican there we don't
talk about venules and mortals anymore
you knew all the degrees of okay I don't
know anything about the Catholic Church
anymore I'm gonna follow
Pope Francis he's showing us bring no
more venal and mortal sins can you
handle it I guess I guess it's been so
long by the way bill you know they're
all just soon you do know an atheist is
the one who's against the theism of the
time it's against the ISM so hey well no
it's just the absence of the ISM not
against our jobs opposing it just saying
that's not real well let's get real
exactly
I couldn't have said it better myself
but I probably did glennda okay uh Doug
we got to do a comedy act
like a sec I could be the dummy you
could be like ladies and gentlemen I'm
so sorry for my atheist coming over here
you know you know all the Woody Allen's
good jokes about I don't believe in the
afterlife but I'm bringing the change
underwear yeah Doug if Trump runs as a
third party candidate will that destroy
any chance of a Republican winning in
2016 it sure doesn't help and that's why
I think he's basically been Hillary
Clinton's unsecret weapon everything he
does I mean you're loving everything
Donald Trump does right I thoroughly
enjoy I mean that's all I could say if
you read the art of the deal his book
and he talks about how you gain leverage
he has got the Republican Party by the
short neck
he's got them by whatever whatever right
by whatever or wherever it's my presence
changing the vocabulary for the better
sister thank you brother sister
is the FBI investigation into Hillary's
email going to come up with anything of
consequence no I agree you know I just
got a email from the State Department IG
is did all my colleagues when I was
chief of staff in the State Department
and we have to now furnish information
to the Inspector General because what we
did with our emails because but because
you have he mails from Hillary I Powell
had a laptop in his office he had
private even a laptop i correspondent
with him on his laptop on AOL steven
gates and george did it so watch out
you're gonna be hauled in yeah I mean I
mean who what do they think they're
gonna find she is the most boring
centrist has seriously this is not Che
Guevara in a pantsuit this is she's just
not that kind of person whatever she got
it's just great at Leslie's these these
emails that were sent to her were later
classified or marked as when there's two
of them marked as classified you know
she she didn't pass them they came to
her and they were later marked as
classified after she turned them back to
the State Department you know it's just
a it's a tie if it hadn't been this
wouldn't it have been something worse I
mean there's it's always something with
the party and that's one of the
challenges is this story reminds a lot
of voters well why they're uneasy with
with Hillary Clinton and look she's done
very well in blaming a lot of things on
the vast right-wing conspiracy and
little secret there is one we have
regular meetings and we've been pretty
productive with it but you can't call
Barack Obama's FBI the vast right-wing
conspiracy and so the pushback that
they're already doing on this these are
the kinds of things that happen when you
run for president just isn't true are
you going after Colin Powell next then
he's not running for presidency Wow no
but we like Aaron Powell but no but he
had the same email set up but it wasn't
the same set up and what we've seen what
we've seen is Hillary Clinton's story
has changed repeatedly it's why she
jumped into the race so quickly and got
ahead of her campaign and you know that
now there were Hillary Clinton's
surrogates I would go on TV with them
who would say I don't know what to say
about the emails cuz I'm not getting any
information that this idea
had there been so many Clinton scandals
wasn't that something fabricated by the
right-wing conspiracy because even in
the Ken Starr report he said I looked
into all of them and I got nothing but
the [ __ ] excuse me sister and also
why why ISM to dirty world I'm not dirty
I know you know what something the death
penalty is obscene
that's right nothing obscene about a
[ __ ] at least in my house that was
doubtful
Jesus is right okay and what will end
with that that question for you I had it
about Owen just headed here oh is
solitary confinement cruel and unusual
punishment yes I would say right when
you go to prison government owns you
no really you do not have civil rights
in a prison you you can be beat up there
was a case that got to the Supreme Court
Louisiana God Angola prison handcuffed
behind his back and the guards beat the
lot out of him broke his nose it came
before the Supreme Court and Clarence
Thomas and Justice Scalia said prison is
a place of pain deal with it and they
did not see this cruel and unusual
punishment you die because you don't get
medical care prison is a terrible place
to be in solitary confinement human
beings we're dialogic we we live because
we ROCK we even do dialog in our own
head right and it drives people to
infinity but they can do anything an
America did a horrible thing some years
ago it decided that when we put people
into prison we can completely forget
about them and they are just horrible
humans who get whatever they deserve and
of course that is such silly thinking
who knows and now we have some truly
horrible people there but most people
are we have more people in prison than
almost any country in the world and most
are there for drugs right the drug war
is a total utter abysmal failure right
we're gonna go prove that there's no
coincidence that you are ward of the
state you know slavery was very
profitable for America Jim Crow is very
profitable for America you need a system
to replace it you have poor people
people of color who will be an overly
criminalized will be ushered into these
the prison industrial complex is to to
talk about the prison industrial complex
and not talk about the racial overtones
that there are that are wise is like
you'd um is is is dishonest and and I
think we but and one of the like an end
on one of the more encouraging notes in
this polarized country where the parties
almost never work together this is
finally something where they are working
together we get they kind of agree on
this that we went too far with the
prison system yeah and we have to undo
it a lot of it's happening in the states
in this day all right thank you very
much that's what
you